REPUBLICANS.
>> Sean: THAT WAS THE
PRESIDENT EARLIER TODAY TALKING
ABOUT DEMOCRAT DELAY TACTICS IN
AN OP-ED ON FOXNews.com.
HE WROTE "IF NOT JUDGE
KAVANAUGH, THEN WHO?
THIS IS THE QUESTION REPUBLICANS
NEED TO ASK THEMSELVES AS THEY
PREPARE FOR THE SENATE JUDICIARY
HEARING.
AND, DIANNE FEINSTEIN LITERALLY
HAD THIS IN JULY.
SHE DIDN'T BRING IT UP UNTIL
NOW.
THEN, THE PEOPLE THAT PROFESSOR
FORD MENTIONED, ALL OF THEM DENY
IT.
THEN YOU HAVE THE NEW YORKER
ARTICLE WHERE MS. RAMIREZ ADMITS
SHE WAS INEBRIATED VERY EARLY,
SLURRING HER WORDS, GAPS IN HER
MEMORY, ET CETERA.
THEN YOU HAVE THE NEW FACE OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY THAT SAYS I
WILL REVEAL GANG RATE IN THE
NEXT 48 HOURS.
AND NOW PEOPLE ASSUME THERE IS
NO PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
>> WELL I THINK WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULD THINK IS
THAT YOU HAVE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
SO DESPERATE TO STOP THE
SUPREME COURT FROM BECOMING
CONSERVATIVE, THAT THEY ARE
PREPARED TO LIE, TO SMEAR, TO BE
HYSTERICAL, TO BREAK SENATE
RULES, TO DO WHATEVER THEY HAVE
TO DO.
WHAT YOU ARE WATCHING IS A PARTY
TOTALLY DESPERATE, AND YOU HAVE
TO PUT THIS WEEK IN CONTEXT.
I WAS STRUCK EARLIER TODAY THAT
ARTHUR MILLER'S A GREAT PLAY THE
CRUCIBLE WHICH IS ABOUT THE
SALEM WITCHCRAFT TRIALS ACTUALLY
RELATES TO US HAPPENING TO JUDGE
WHAT HE IS BEING PRINT       PUT
WHAT HE IS BEING PRINT       PUR
WHAT HE IS BEING PRINT       PUU
WHAT HE IS BEING PRINT       PUH
WHAT HE IS BEING PRINT       PUI
KAVANAUGH.
WHAT HE IS BEING PRINT       PUS
LIKE MEDIEVAL TORTURE.
SOMEONE SHOWS UP 35 YEARS LATER,
AND EVERYONE IN THE AUDIENCE
OUGHT TO THINK ABOUT THIS.
CLOSE YOUR EYES FOR A SECOND,
AND ASK WHAT WERE YOU DOING ON
JUNE 12TH, 35 YEARS AGO?
THE TRUTH IS, YOU ALMOST
CERTAINLY DON'T KNOW.
THE FACT IS, THIS HEARING IS A
FARCE.
THERE IS NOTHING KAVANAUGH CAN
SAY WHICH WILL CONVINCE
CHUCK SCHUMER TO VOTE FOR HIM
AND I THINK THAT DR. FORD AS NO
EVIDENCE OTHER THAN HER OWN
WORD, WHICH IS GOING TO COUNT --
THEY CAN'T PROVIDE ANY WITNESSES
AND AND CAN'T EVEN PROVIDE TO
THE BEST OF MY KNOWLEDGE, WHAT
WAS THE DATE, WHERE WAS THE
HOUSE, AND AT WHAT POINT IS THE
BURDEN OF COMMON SENSE ON THE
ACCUSER, AND IF IT'S A BURDEN OF
COMMON SENSE, THIS HEARING
WOULDN'T EVEN BE HELD.
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH SENATOR   T
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH SENATOR   E
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH SENATOR   S
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH SENATOR   N
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH SENATOR   T
IT'S ONLY IN THE CURRENT HYPER
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH SENATOR   R
CAN SAY, MEN CAN JUST SHUT UP.
I MEAN, WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO
AMERICA WHEN RANDOM LEFT-WING
TOTALITARIANS THINK THEY CAN
VIOLATE PRIVATE PROPERTY,
TRESPASS AND A RESTAURANT, GO IN
AND INTIMIDATE A CITIZEN WHO IS
SIMPLY TRYING TO HAVE DINNER,
AND THEY THINK THEY ARE HEROES.
APPARENTLY, THE POLICE ARE
CALLED AND NOBODY IS ARRESTED
FOR TRESPASS AND NO ONE IS
ARRESTED FOR INTIMIDATION.
WE ARE WATCHING.
WHERE, WHAT WE OUGHT TO
UNDERSTAND IS, THIS IS ABOUT RAW
POWER.
IF THE LEFT CAN STOP CAVANAUGH,
WE WILL NOT GET ANOTHER
CONSERVATIVE JUSTICE IN OUR
LIFETIME ON THE SUPREME COURT.
>> Sean: IF YOU TALK ABOUT HIS
FOUR DECADES AS AN EXEMPLARY
HUSBAND, FATHER, FRIEND.
JUDGE, THERE HAVE BEEN OVER 220
PEOPLE THAT HAVE COME OUT AND
SAID THIS GUY IS A CUT ABOVE.
THE GENTLEMAN'S GENTLEMAN.
AND THEN I AM LISTENING TO THESE
LAWMAKERS, MANY OF THEM, WHEN
THEY SAY, I BELIEVE IN THE CASE
OF PROFESSOR FORD OR
MR. RAMIREZ, BUT WHAT THEY SAY
IS THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN DUE
PROCESS OR THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
I HAVE TO BE HONEST, HOW DOES A
LAWMAKER SAY HE HAS TO PROVE HIS
INNOCENCE?
WE HAVE HAD LAWMAKERS SAY THAT.
SENATOR SAYS HE HAS TO PROVE HIS
INNOCENCE FROM 40 YEARS AGO, OR
36 YEARS AGO.
>> THERE IS A WHOLE BLOCK OF
LEFT-WING DEMOCRATS WHETHER IT'S
SCHUMER OR A VARIETY OF OTHER
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT.
THEY ARE HOPELESS.
THEY HAVE NO INTEREST IN THE
TRUTHS, INVOLVED IN THE STRUGGLE
OVER POWER AND THEY HAVE TO PAY
OFF THEIR ACTIVIST BASE.
THERE IS NO POSSIBILITY THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO VOTE FOR JUDGE
KAVANAUGH.
BUT WHAT I'M FASCINATED WITH
HIS, LET'S SAY YOU ARE THE
SENATOR FROM WEST VIRGINIA OR
MISSOURI OR INDIANA OR
NORTH DAKOTA, ARMENTANO, NOW,
YOU ARE FROM AN AREA WHERE THERE
ARE LOTS OF COMMON SENSE
EVERYDAY FOLKS WHO LIKE
DONALD TRUMP, WHO BELIEVE
DONALD TRUMP IS DOING THE RIGHT
THING, WHO WANT TO HAVE A MORE
CONSERVATIVE COURT.
LET'S SAY THE JUNIOR SENATOR
FROM ALABAMA, DO YOU REALLY WANT
TO LINE UP WITH CHUCK SCHUMER
AND THE LEFT, WITH BOOKER AND
HIS POLE      PATHETIC PORTRAITF
SPARTACUS?
AND I BET HE HAD NO IDEA WHO
SPARTACUS WAS.
I THINK THESE SENATORS WHO ARE
FROM STATES THAT HAVE A LOT OF
COMMON SENSE AND A LOT OF
CONSERVATISM, A DESIRE FOR MORE
CONSERVATIVE JUDGES, WE HAVE NOT
HEARD A SINGLE ONE OF THEM YET
AND I WILL BE VERY SURPRISED IF
WE DON'T HAVE A NUMBER OF THEM
VOTE YES.
REMEMBER, WHEN THE CLARENCE
THOMAS CHARACTER ASSASSINATION
WAS UNDERWAY, 11 DEMOCRATS ENDED
UP VOTING YES FOR CLARENCE
THOMAS.
AND I THINK WE MAY FIND ALL OF A
SUDDEN, THAT SEVERAL OF THESE
DEMOCRATS FROM TRUMP STATES
DECIDED IN THE END.
YOU KNOW, SHE DIDN'T PROVE HER
CASE, I'M GOING TO VOTE YES.
HE DESERVES TO BE ON THE COURT.
>> Sean: HE ALSO HAS A 40 YEAR
TRACK RECORD.
I THINK YOUR OBSERVATION IS
RIGHT, 42 DAYS IN THE ELECTION,
I CAN TELL YOU THAT PEOPLE THAT
I HEAR FROM THREE HOURS PER DAY
ON RADIO THAT WATCH THE SHOW,
THEY ARE ANGRY.
INSTINCTIVELY AMERICANS BELIEVE
IN DUE PROCESS, THEY BELIEVE IN
FUNDAMENTAL FAIRNESS, AND WE
BELIEVE IN HIGH-PROFILE CASES,
AND WE ARE SEEING A RUSH TO
JUDGMENT WITH A LOT OF THE SAME
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN WRONG AGAIN AND
AGAIN, AND THOSE FOUR PEOPLE
HAVE CONTROL.
THAT WOULD BE BOB CORKER, THAT
WOULD BE JEFF FLAKE.
I THINK SUSAN COLLINS PROBABLY
HAD THE BEST COMMENT OF ANYBODY
SAYING, WHAT DIANNE FEINSTEIN
DID WAS UNFAIR TO EVERYBODY IN
THIS CASE, AND, LISA MURKOWSKI,
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT FROM
ANY OF THEM TONIGHT.
>> I DON'T EITHER.
THURSDAY IS IMPORTANT IN THE
FACT THAT UNLESS DR. FORD IS
I'M GUESSING ALL FOUR OF THE   T
I'M GUESSING ALL FOUR OF THE   E
OVERWHELMINGLY CONVINCING AND
I'M GUESSING ALL FOUR OF THE   M
WILL REALIZE THERE IS NO CASE
ADEQUATE TO SAY NO.
AT THE SAME TIME, I BELIEVE
THERE ARE FIVE OR SIX DEMOCRATS
ON THE BUBBLE WHO HAVE TO GO
HOME AND EXPLAIN WHY THEY VOTED
WITH SCHUMER AND WITH A WARRANT
AND WHY THEY VOTED WITH BOOKER.
AND I THINK THAT THIS COULD BE A
VERY EXPENSIVE VOTE IN TERMS OF
DEFEATING FIVE, SIX OR SEVEN
DEMOCRATS BECAUSE I THINK THE
STATES WILL SAY TO THEM, THERE
IS NO PROOF HERE THAT JUSTIFIES
VOTING NO ON JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
>> Sean: MR. SPEAKER, WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
SORRY YOU COULDN'T MAKE IT HERE.
YOU ARE IN D.C. AND YOU COULDN'T
EVEN COME SEE US.
WE ARE OUTSIDE ON THE CAPITAL IS
BEHIND US, IT'S BEAUTIFUL.